okay I'm Johanna Stern and I'm a puppy
spy I'm not proud but when I'm not home
this Dropcam frou that's recording me
right now is pointed at my dog and then
through the app I watch him to make sure
he hasn't pooped on the carpet or you
know gone out to have some fun then last
week I began having serious doubts about
my surveillance
I mean surveillance system yes I just
said that nest the Google owned company
that bought Dropcam last year released
this the $200 nest cam it has a 1080p
camera improved night vision and because
even our webcams need to be slimmer a
new design hello test one two
so does this nest cam now make my old
drop cam look like the dog poop and in a
crowded market of do-it-yourself
security cameras is it the best one to
buy the new nest cam and the drop cam
Pro look like they are straight out of a
before and after weight loss ad that's
not a reason to upgrade but the new
stand is actually very useful it now has
a built-in magnet so you can stick it to
your fridge and it also rotates easier
let's improve the design of its app -
and I really prefer it to the others but
the big difference is in picture quality
right well sort of here's what I found
out very quickly a 1080p versus a 720p
camera makes very little difference if
you're just watching your pet especially
when the camera is five to ten feet away
and you view it on your phone the higher
resolution makes sense though if you're
using it as a security camera to catch
the bad guys
on a high resolution computer screen you
can see the difference take this shot of
me as a fake burglar 15 feet away from
the camera with the nest cam I was able
to zoom in and see the intruders face
slightly better at least compared to a
720p camera like the Dropcam pro and the
$200 simply can and when the lights go
out
Nest's night-vision footage is crisper
and objects are easier to make out the
speaker on the nest which lets you use
your phone like a walkie-talkie
is also louder than the other
step away yes cam but where Ness could
use some help is with motion detection
notifications
I still get alerted sometimes when my
puppy walks across the apartment and I
get the same alert when that burglar
takes my computer monitor simply cam is
better at pet detection and it even lets
you register your face so you don't get
alerts about yourself although it
doesn't always work very well
so we're sticking with the Dropcam pro I
just don't need the extra resolution to
spy on this little guy but if you're in
the market for one of these the new nest
cam is the leader of the pack the
biggest downside is the $10 a month
subscription fee just like the drop cam
which you have to pay to be able to
rewind and review the footage it can
quickly add up but for some of us the
price is worth the peace of mind